I think the problem hasn't been with
literature it's been with literary
critics and quite frankly literary
criticism is basically in the process of
destroying itself hi I'm Michael
Moynihan with reason TV and today we're
with paul cantor a professor of English
at the University of Virginia and
adjunct scholar at the ludwig von mises
institute an author most recently of
literature in the economics of Liberty
what are you hoping to bring to sort of
literary studies with this with this
volume well this is an attempt to show
that people believe in free markets and
capitalism can have something to say
about literature almost all the
criticism that deals with economic
aspects of literature's broadly
left-wing very frequently Marxist or
neo-marxist and we just wanted to show
that you can believe in capitalism
believe in the power of markets and
still show something interesting about
literature are there pieces in this book
that speak to today's financial crisis
well I'm afraid there are I wrote one
piece on Tomas man's story disorderly
sorrow which is said in Germany at the
time of the hyperinflation and it's
really remarkable brilliant analysis of
the psychological and cultural effects
of inflation how it distorts markets how
it distorts people's lives how it gives
the young an advantage over the old the
poor old living on pensions fixed
incomes young people able to adjust to
the new volatility in markets and I hate
to say it but for the first time my
lifetime there's some chance we may
experience high inflation or
hyperinflation in this country so that
sa may be relevant previously and
obviously you know the scholarship in
these areas previously had anyone
through the pointed out that they're
kind of libertarian or free market or
pro Liberty type themes in these books
virtually no one Fred Turner's one of
the few people thats ever written a pro
capitalist work of the Ray criticism on
Shakespeare and there's a guy named
Russell Berman who recently came out
with a book called fiction sets you free
but otherwise we're in an open market
here
why are professors in your field so
predominantly of the left well I'll go
back to what both Friedrich Hayek and
look if and beezus have written
particularly muses book the anti
capitalistic mentality professors are
smart they often are very talented and
they look around the world and they see
that they're not as financially rewarded
by the market as people they think of
their intellectual inferiors and that's
one of the real sources of the
anti-capitalist bias of a lot of
professors but we have a couple of
essays on that subject Steve Cox's essay
on Connor into the secret agent is all
about a disinfectant should be
disinfected disaffected intelligentsia
just seething with envy and resentment
and that's why they're utopian and want
to see the overthrow of the current
order and I've been essay on hg wells on
his book The Invisible Man which by the
way I show is his version of Adam
Smith's invisible hand and it's an
anti-capitalist screen as a result but I
show there that Wells as an author was
used to central planning he was used to
planning out all his books perfectly
ahead of time moving his characters
around like pieces on a chessboard and
he came to believe that's the way
society should be run where do you see
students these days obviously you're
interacting with them in my classes
pretty what do you see them going
politically is it is it left-right
libertarian is it something a unique
time for I don't think it's a massive
shift i think libertarianism has become
much more popular i've noticed that that
students pick up my work online and and
are interested that there's some
professor at the university is
interested in libertarianism i think the
left is somewhat paralyzed and has no
real viable agenda and and and that's
weakening its hold on students and to
some extent we're seeing some reaction
against political correctness students
don't like that and so they're
gravitating in the other direction again
I don't think this is something massive
but I've never
seen more students interested in
libertarianism quite frankly a lot were
energized by ron paul's campaign and
were quite struck that i knew him and
wanted to hear more about that so there
are some signs for hope yeah I mean it's
it's a curious thing there isn't because
I mean so many people had predicted as
the economy was the wheels were coming
off of it that this would be a great
moment for the anti-capitalist cause
people like Naomi Klein saying you know
we must seize this opportunity why do
you why do you think that that Ron Paul
had such this sort of enormous
groundswell of support among students
especially was very surprising in a time
when you would expect them to say hey
the markets failed us it's very helpful
to have the truth on your side and I do
think organizations like reason the
felices Institute have really gotten the
message out there and we're seeing the
benefits of the age of the Internet that
students are bypassing the mainstream
media the mainstream academics and they
are reaching this message that free
markets work and it's not that hard to
show that these problems are the result
of government intervention and not of
the ordinary workings of the market what
would you say is the sort of best
argument for studying literature in the
21st century well I do think literature
still has a lot to tell us about human
beings and their interaction I think the
problem hasn't been with literature it's
been with literary critics and quite
frankly literary criticism is basically
in the process of destroying itself if
for no other reason that it's taking a
stand against books this is a good
example with Marx's criticism you're
constantly showing the false
consciousness of authors if they support
capitalism is because they're the paid
lackeys of the capitalist class one
thing we do in our book is we look at
authors as genuine thinkers we take
their thinking seriously I think if
there were more of that students could
come to respect to authors more Paul
thanks for coming thank you for having
me here for reason TV I'm Michael
Moynihan perfect